[Music]
lilly Reinhardt says being body shamed
took a toll on her self-esteem I think a
lot of people say you should just sweep
it under the rug
eet's he caught up with the 21 year old
Riverdale star during the 2018 CFDA
Fashion Awards in New York City on
Monday where she opened up about
speaking out against internet trolls
starting pregnancy rumors over her
weight I feel like a lot of people say
you should just sweep it under the rug
don't pay attention to it but that's
never really been my style and maybe
some people find that obnoxious whatever
but oh I felt the need to say something
and so you know no I'm I'm not pregnant
and also if I was it's kind of sad that
people felt the need to just make my
weight a topic of conversation
I mean it's but as that's just the world
we live in but I'm gonna always speak
out about something that I feel I need
to talk about it was bugging me and in
at first it was really upsetting and you
know you don't want to 21 I'm not I'm
not pregnant you don't want people look
I don't people think I'm pregnant if I'm
not pregnant so you know it did take a
hit to my self-esteem for a second and
then I kind of picked myself back up and
said I'm not gonna let this ruin my day
[Music]
[Applause]